Back when he was active in the gang, on the street every day, Danny Toro had a routine. Come home from school at 3:00, help his mom out with anything she needed help with, and then, before he went out with his boys, he would sit down and watch a movie. For a while, it was Scarface, the 1983 Al Pacino movie about a Cuban gangster who's so tough, he doesn't betray his friends even when a guy is about to hack him up with a chainsaw. He's fearless. He's lethal. And he wants it all.
丹尼·托罗在帮派活跃的日子里，每天走在街头都有个固定的流程。下午3点放学回家，帮母亲做任何她需要帮忙的事，然后在他和伙伴们出去之前，他会坐下来看一部电影。有一阵子，那是《疤面煞星》，这部1983年阿尔·帕西诺主演的电影讲述了一个古巴黑帮分子的故事，他非常强硬，即使有人要用电锯把他大卸八块，他也不会背叛朋友。他无所畏惧。他冷酷致命。而且他想要得到一切。
That was like a motivation movie there. It got the blood pumping and the adrenaline going. I watch it right before I come out, so I'm already there. I'm in that point. I go pick up a couple of my friends.
那电影就像是一种动力源。它让人热血沸腾，肾上腺素飙升。我会在出门前看它，这样我就已经进入状态了。我已经在那儿了。然后我就去接我的几个朋友。
Pumped up.
热血沸腾。
Yeah. Go out like a gangster. If a movie was as good as I wanted it to be, I'll watch it once a day for months at a time. Scarface, I watched it over and over and over. And the times when I didn't have time to watch the whole movie, I'd just watch the first part or the second part, depending on how I felt, what kind of stage of mind I wanted to be in.
是的。像个黑帮一样走出去。如果一部电影像我期望的那样精彩，我会在几个月里每天都看一遍。《疤面煞星》，我一遍又一遍地看。有时候没时间看完整部电影，我就只看第一部分或第二部分，取决于我当时的感觉，以及我想要进入什么样的心理状态。
The movie The Godfather begins with the sentence, "I believe in America." And I think any gangster's life is a particularly mesmerizing parable of America, because it contains all the things that we're not supposed to want, easy money, drugs, alcohol, glamorous, feral sex, plus all those values that we think of as core American values, loyalty to friends and family, ambition, independence, self-motivation, not taking no for an answer. So it's easy to see why civilians like you and me go to gangster movies. But I was curious what gangsters actually get out of them.
电影《教父》的开头是这句话：“我相信美国。”我认为任何黑帮的生活都是一个特别迷人的美国寓言，因为它包含了所有我们不该追求的东西：不义之财、毒品、酒精、迷人而野性的性爱，再加上所有我们认为是美国核心价值观的东西：对朋友和家人的忠诚、野心、独立、自我激励、从不接受拒绝。所以很容易理解为什么像你我这样的普通人会去看黑帮电影。但我很好奇黑帮分子实际上从电影中得到了什么。
For 10 years, Danny Toro was active in a Chicago street gang. He says that the old-school gangster films, like The Godfather movies, they just didn't do it for him.
丹尼·托罗在芝加哥街头帮派活跃了10年。他说，老派黑帮电影，比如《教父》系列，对他来说并没有什么共鸣。
I watched them once or twice. They were all right, but it wasn't what I was looking for. I was looking for how I live. The way I used to live while I was gang banging was very different. It wasn't so organized. It wasn't so where I kiss you on the cheek, and then you're dying. No, it wasn't like that. Things were more said up front.
我看了过一两次。它们还行，但不是我想要的。我在寻找我生活方式的投射。我混帮派时的生活方式和电影里很不一样。它没那么有组织。不像电影里那样亲吻脸颊后对方就死定了。不，不是那样的。事情往往更直接地摆在台面上。
So it was like I was looking to movies more to where I could relate the way my lifestyle was like. Scarface was right there in your face. He didn't care who you were, just like that one scene, he says, "Only thing as I got is my word and my balls. And I don't break 'em for nobody." And it's kind of true. Because out here, you don't got much. And if you break that, what do you got? Nothing.
所以我看电影更多是为了寻找能和我生活方式产生共鸣的内容。《疤面煞星》就非常直白。他不在乎你是谁，就像那一幕，他说：“我只有我的言语和胆量。我不会为任何人破坏它们。”这在某种程度上是真的。因为在这里，你没什么可依靠的。如果你连这都破坏了，你还剩下什么？什么都没有。
Danny's favorite film was this movie about Lucky Luciano. His favorite scenes were the ones where guys backed each other up in a fight not because they thought they'd get anything out of backing each other up, but because it was the right thing to do.
丹尼最喜欢的电影是关于幸运卢西亚诺的那部。他最喜欢的片段是那些打架时同伴互相支持的情节，不是因为他们觉得能从中得到什么好处，而是因为那是正确的事。
That's what I wanted to see out here. Don't do something to get something back. Do it because you became a part of it, and that's part of you, so contribute to it.
这就是我想在这里看到的。不要为了得到什么回报才去做事。去做，是因为你已经成为了它的一部分，而那是你的一部分，所以为之贡献。
He especially liked Lucky, because of all the movie gangsters, Lucky seemed to have the best judgment when it came to people.
他特别喜欢卢西亚诺，因为在所有电影黑帮中，卢西亚诺在识人方面似乎最有判断力。
He knew how to take care of things. He knew how to punish without overpunishing. He knew how to correct people in a polite way.
他知道如何处理事情。他知道如何惩罚，但不过度惩罚。他知道如何礼貌地纠正别人。
Danny even picked up a move or two from Lucky.
丹尼甚至从卢西亚诺身上学到了几招。
One time I had sat down with the guys kind of like he used to do, sit there and talk with each other. Like, when Lucky's wife got killed, they all got together. They were sympathizing, just like when I had two guys, and they were brothers, and one of the brothers died.
有一次我和伙伴们坐在一起，就像他过去那样，坐下来谈心。比如，当卢西亚诺的妻子被杀时，他们聚在了一起。他们表示同情，就像我有两个伙计是兄弟，其中一个兄弟死了，我当时就在那儿试图安慰他们之类的。
And I was there trying to comfort and whatnot. And I said, Don't worry about it. Things'll work out. And their people caught on, too, how it was that things would work out. And try to have that family base I guess you could say to show that I really loved them.
我说，别担心。事情会解决的。他们也领会了，事情会好转的。我想可以说，尽量保持那种家庭基础，以此展示我真的关心他们。
And you got that way of acting from the movie?
你是从电影里学到这种行为方式的吗？
Yeah. Because when I first started learning about what a gang banger was or gang member, it was like your heart-- you're right there. You ain't got no fear. You have no compassion.
是的。因为当我刚开始了解什么是帮派分子时，感觉就像你的心——你就在那个点上。你没有恐惧。你没有同情心。
Right. You gotta be hard.
对。你必须强硬。
That's it. You're a gang banger, you're a gang banger. And you're some cruel criminal or whatever you want to call it.
就是这样。你是黑帮成员，就是黑帮成员。不管你想怎么称呼，你就是一个残酷的罪犯。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it is This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, gangsters, the ones in movies and the ones in real life, and how the two intersect. Act One, The Freshman, why a college student in Montana would be watching The Godfather every single day, and what happens when she follows her obsession to Sicily.
来自WBEZ芝加哥和国际公共广播电台，这里是《此美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天我们的节目主题是黑帮，电影里的和现实生活中的，以及这两者如何交织。第一幕：新生，为什么蒙大拿州的一个大学生会每天看《教父》，当她追随执念前往西西里岛时会发生什么。
Act Two, Mobster's Daughter. The true story of two different people born into the mob. Act Three, My Neighbor John Gotti, the true story of what it's like to live across the street from the place where the head of New York's Gambino crime family has his little parties, plus much, much more. Stay with us.
第二幕：黑帮女儿。两个出生在黑帮家庭的人的真实故事。第三幕：我的邻居约翰·戈蒂，住在纽约甘比诺犯罪家族头目举办小型聚会的地点对面的真实生活体验，以及更多内容。请留下来。
Act One, The Freshman. Sarah Vowell says that back in the days when she watched The Godfather every single day, she never really told anybody about it because she was afraid that her friends would interpret it as some sort of cry for help. She would watch The Godfather surreptitiously, when no roommates were around. She'd stop the videotape if the phone rang. Here then, the true story of one woman's cross-cultural immersion.
第一幕：新生。莎拉·沃威尔说，在那些每天看《教父》的日子里，她从未告诉过任何人，因为她怕朋友们会把这解读为某种求救信号。她会偷偷看《教父》，确保没有室友在场。如果电话响了，她会暂停录像带。下面，讲述一位女性跨文化沉浸的真实故事。
There comes a time in the middle of any halfway decent liberal arts major's college career when she no longer has any idea what she believes. She flies violently through air polluted by conflicting ideas and theories, never stopping at one system of thought long enough to feel at home. All those books, all that talk, and, oh, the self-reflection. Am I an existentialist? A Taoist? A transcendentalist? A modernist? A post-modernist? A relativist? Positivist? Historicist? Anarchist? Dadaist? Deconstructionist? Was I Apollonian or Dionysian? Which was right, and which was wrong? Impressionism or expressionism? And while we're at it, is there such a thing as right and wrong?
任何一个半吊子文科专业学生在大学生涯中总会有一个时刻，不再知道自己信仰什么。她们在冲突的观点和理论所污染的空气中剧烈地飞行，从未在一个思想体系中停留得足够久以感到自在。所有的书，所有的谈话，噢，还有自我反省。我是存在主义者吗？道家？超验主义者？现代主义者？后现代主义者？相对主义者？实证主义者？历史主义者？无政府主义者？达达主义者？解构主义者？我是阿波罗式还是狄俄尼索斯式？哪个是对的，哪个是错的？印象派还是表现派？顺便问一句，这世上有对与错吗？
Until I figured out that the flight between questions is, itself, a workable system, I craved answers, rules, a code. And so I spent part of every week, sometimes every day, watching The Godfather on videotape. I wanted to cower in the dark brown rooms of Don Corleone, kiss his hand on his daughter's wedding day, explain what's wrong with me, and let him tell me he'll make everything all right.
直到我意识到，在问题之间的飞行本身就是一个可行的系统，我渴望答案、规则、准则。所以，我每周的一部分时间，有时甚至每天，都在看《教父》的录像带。我想蜷缩在唐·柯里昂那深棕色的房间里，在他女儿婚礼那天吻他的手，解释我的困扰，让他告诉我一切都会好起来。
Someday, and that day may never come, I'll call upon you to do a service for me. But until that day, accept this justice as a gift on my daughter's wedding day.
也许有一天，而那一天也许永远不会到来，我会请你为我效劳。但在那一天到来之前，请在小女婚礼之日接受这份公正。
Grazie, Godfather.
谢谢，教父。
Prego.
不用客气。
Looking back, I wonder why a gangster movie kidnapped my life. The Godfather had nothing to do with me. I was a feminist, not Italian, and I lived in Montana. I had never set foot in New York, thought ravioli came only in a can, and wasn't blind to the fact that all the women in the movie were either virgins, mothers, whores, or Diane Keaton.
回首往事，我纳闷为什么一部黑帮电影绑架了我的生活。《教父》和我毫无关系。我是个女权主义者，不是意大利人，住在蒙大拿州。我从未踏足纽约，认为馄饨只存在于罐头里，也并非没意识到电影里的女性要么是处女、母亲、妓女，要么就是黛安·基顿。
But I fell for those made-up, sexist, East Coast thugs anyway. Partly, it was the clothes, because fashion-wise, there is nothing less glamorous than snow-blown, backpacky college life in the Rocky Mountain states. But I think what really attracted me to the film was that it offered a three-hour peep into a world with clear and definable moral guidelines, where you know where you stand and you know who you love, where honor is everything and the greatest sin isn't murder, but betrayal.
但我还是迷上了那些编造的、性别歧视的东海岸恶棍。部分原因是服装，因为在时尚方面，没有什么比落基山脉地区那种大雪纷飞、背着背包的大学生活更缺乏魅力的了。但我认为真正吸引我的是，它提供了三个小时的窗口，让人窥见一个拥有清晰明确道德准则的世界，在那里你知道自己的立场，知道自己爱谁，荣誉高于一切，最大的罪恶不是谋杀，而是背叛。
The Godfather is a film crammed with rules for living. Don't bow down to big shots. It's good when people owe you. This drug businesses is dangerous. Is vengeance going to bring your son back to you or my boy to me? And the ever popular--
《教父》是一部塞满了生活规则的电影。不要向大人物低头。别人欠你人情是件好事。毒品生意很危险。复仇能让你儿子回来，或者能让我的孩子回来吗？还有那句广为流传的——
What's the matter with  you? I think your brain is going soft. Never tell anybody outside the family what you're thinking again.
你怎么了？我觉得你的脑子变软了。永远不要再告诉家族以外的人你在想什么。
My favorite scene in the film takes place on a deserted highway with the Statue of Liberty in the background. The Don's henchman, Clemenza, is on the road with two of his men, and he's under orders that only one of them's supposed to make the ride back.
我最喜欢的电影场景发生在一条荒凉的高速公路上，背景是自由女神像。唐的亲信克莱门扎和他的两个手下在路上，他接到命令，只有其中一个人能活着回来。
[SOUND OF THREE GUNSHOTS]
[三声枪响]
The grizzly, back-of-the-head murder of a rat fink associate is all in a day's work. But Clemenza's overriding responsibility is to his family. And he takes a moment out of his routine madness to remember that he had promised his wife he'll bring desert home. His instruction to his partner in crime is an entire moral manifesto in six little words.
枪杀一个告密的叛徒只是日常工作。但克莱门扎首要的责任是对他的家庭。他在例行的疯狂中抽空想起，他曾答应过妻子要带甜点回家。他对他犯罪同伙的指示，六个字就是一个完整的道德宣言。
Leave the gun. Take the cannoli.
放下枪。带走甜点。
I'd been raised as a fundamentalist in a small town in Oklahoma. And by the time I got to college, I was a recent, and therefore shaky, atheist. Like a lot of once-devout people who have lost religion, I had holes the size of heaven and hell inside my head and my heart. I had had a God, commandments, faith, the promise of redemption, and a Bible, the Bible, which offered an explanation of everything from creation on through to the end of the world. And now God was dead, and I had whacked him. And when he was gone, what was left? Only question marks.
我是在俄克拉荷马州的一个小镇上作为原教旨主义者长大的。到了大学时，我成了一个新晋的、因此并不稳固的无神论者。像许多失去了信仰的前虔诚者一样，我的脑海和心里有像天堂和地狱那么大的空洞。我曾经拥有上帝、诫命、信仰、救赎的承诺，以及圣经——那本圣经，它提供了从创世到世界末日的一切解释。现在上帝死了，而且是我干掉了他。当他离去，还剩下什么？只有问号。
Don Corleone, the godfather, was not unlike God, the father, loving and indulgent one minute, wrathful and judgmental the next. But the only "Thou shalt" in the Don's dogma was to honor thy family. He dances with his wife, weeps over his son's corpse, and dies playing in the garden with his grandson.
唐·柯里昂，教父，就像上帝一样，父亲，一会儿慈爱宽容，一会儿愤怒审判。但在唐的教条中，唯一的“诫命”就是荣誉家族。他与妻子共舞，为儿子的尸体哭泣，并死在与孙子玩耍的花园里。
You spend time with your family?
你花时间陪家人吗？
Sure, I do.
当然。
Good, because a man who doesn't spend time with his family can never be a real man.
好，因为一个不花时间陪伴家人的男人，永远成不了真正的男人。
Don Corleone wouldn't have paid actual money to sit in fluorescent-lit rooms listening to frat boys from Spokane babble on about Descartes. Don Corleone had no time for mind games and conjecture. I, on the other hand, had nothing but time for such things, probably because I'm a frivolous female.
唐·柯里昂绝不会花真钱坐在荧光灯下的房间里，听斯波坎来的兄弟会小伙子们唠叨笛卡尔。唐·柯里昂没时间玩思想游戏和推测。而我，另一方面，却有大把时间做这些，大概因为我是一个轻浮的女性。
I spent my life trying not to be careless. Women and the children can be careless, but not men.
我一生都在努力不要粗心大意。女人和孩子可以粗心大意，但男人不行。
Christmas break. I sign up for a semester of art history in Holland and fly to Europe a few weeks early. I get on a train in Vienna, and another in Berlin, and another after that. And one thing leads to another. And not thinking I was heading there, suddenly, I find myself-- surprise-- in Italy. How did that happen? Oh well, as long as I'm in Florence, might as well pop down and give Sicily a look-see.
寒假。我报名参加了荷兰的艺术史课程，提前几周飞往欧洲。我在维也纳坐上一列火车，又在柏林坐上另一列，之后又是另一列。事情一件接着一件。在没想过要去那里的情况下，突然，我发现自己——惊喜——身在意大利了。这是怎么发生的？好吧，既然到了佛罗伦萨，不如顺便去西西里岛看看。
Have I mentioned how I love that part of The Godfather when Michael's hiding out there, traipsing around his ancestral hills, walking the streets of his father's birthplace, Corleone? I take a night train from Rome down the boot and wake up in the Sicilian capital, Palermo. I feel ridiculous. I thought of myself as a serious person, and it didn't seem like serious people traveled hundreds of miles out of their way to walk in the footsteps of Al Pacino.
我提到过我有多喜欢《教父》里迈克尔躲在那里，走过他祖先的山丘，走在父亲出生地科里昂街头的那部分吗？我从罗马坐夜车南下，在西西里首府巴勒莫醒来。我觉得自己很可笑。我以为自己是一个严肃的人，但严肃的人似乎不会为了走一遍阿尔·帕西诺走过的路而绕行数百英里。
Still, I feel silly being there, but not so silly that I'm above tracking down a bakery and buying, yes, a cannoli, my first. I walk down to the sea and eat it. It's sweeter than I thought it would be, more dense, and the filling's flecked with chocolate and candied orange. Clemenza was right, leave that gun. Take that cannoli.
尽管如此，我感到身处此地很傻，但还没傻到不屑于去找家面包店买个甜点——没错，我的第一个甜点。我走到海边吃掉它。它比我想象中更甜，密度更高，馅料里点缀着巧克力和糖渍橙皮。克莱门扎说得对，放下那把枪，带走那甜点。
The town of Corleone really exists and can be reached by bus. Believe me, I checked. Every morning, I'd go to the travel office in Palermo to buy a ticket to the Godfather's hometown. And every morning, when I stand before the ticket agent, I can never quite bring myself to say the word "Corleone" out loud to a real, live Sicilian, because you know they know. Idiot Americans and their idiot films. I have my dignity.
科里昂镇确实存在，而且可以坐公交车到达。相信我，我查过了。每天早上，我都会去巴勒莫的旅行社买一张去教父故乡的车票。每天早上，当我站在售票员面前时，我总是无法在一个活生生的西西里人面前大声说出“科里昂”这个词，因为你知道他们懂的。白痴美国人及其白痴电影。我还有我的尊严。
So each morning, when the ticket agent asks, "Where to?" one of two things happens. I say nothing, and just walk off, and spend the day in Palermo reading John Irving novels on a bench by the sea. Or I utter the name of a proper, art-historically significant town instead, as if the clerk will hear me say, "Agrigento," and say to himself, "Oh, she's going to see the Doric temple. Impressive. Wonder if she's free for a cannoli later?"
所以每天早上，当售票员问“去哪？”时，会有两种情况发生。我什么都不说，直接走开，在巴勒莫的海边长椅上读着约翰·欧文的小说度过一天。或者我说出一个真正有艺术史意义的城镇名称，好像售票员会听到我说“阿格里真托”，然后对自己说，“噢，她要去参观多立克神庙。真了不起。不知道她待会儿有没有空去吃甜点？”
So on my final day in Sicily, my last chance at Corleone, I walk to the ticket counter, look in the clerk's eyes, and ask for a round-trip ticket to Corle-- Cefalu, yeah, Cefalu. That's it. To see a Byzantine mosaic I remember liking in one of my school books.
所以在我西西里之行的最后一天，去科里昂的最后机会，我走到售票柜台，看着售票员的眼睛，要求买一张去科里——切法卢，对，切法卢。就是它。去看看我记得在一本校书里很喜欢的拜占庭马赛克。
Cefalu might as well have been Corleone. It had the same steep, cobblestone streets and blanched, little buildings that I remembered from the movie. "Lovely," I thought, as I started walking up the hill to its tiny, 12th-century cathedral. "Freak," everyone in the town thought as I marched past them. An entire class of schoolchildren stopped cold to gawk at me. Six-year-old girls pointed at my shoes and laughed.
切法卢和科里昂没什么两样。它有着我从电影里记忆中熟悉的陡峭鹅卵石街道和白色小楼。“可爱，”当我开始向山上的12世纪小教堂走去时，我心想。“怪胎，”镇上的每个人在我走过时心想。一整群小学生停下来盯着我看。六岁的小女孩指着我的鞋子大笑。
Hunched, old men glared as if the sight of me was a vicious insult. I felt like a living, breathing faux pas. At least no one was inside the church. The only eyes upon me there were those of the looming, sad-eyed Messiah.
驼背的老人们怒目而视，仿佛我的出现是一种恶毒的侮辱。我觉得自己是一个活生生的失礼行为。至少教堂里没有人。那里唯一盯着我的眼睛是那位忧郁的弥赛亚。
The Jesus in this mosaic is huge, three times larger than any other figure in the church. And there's something menacing in the way he holds that tablet with the word of God on it. But his eyes are compassionate. And that contradictory mix of stern judgment and heart, he may as well have been wearing a tuxedo, and holding a cat, and saying something like--
这个马赛克里的耶稣巨大无比，是教堂里其他人物的三倍大。他拿着刻有上帝之言的牌匾的样子有些威胁感。但他的眼神是慈悲的。而那种严厉审判与慈悲的矛盾混合，他看起来就像穿着燕尾服，抱着猫，说着类似这样的话——
What have I ever done to make you treat me so disrespectfully?
我做过什么让你如此不尊重我？
I leave the church and go for lunch. I am the only patron at a tiny family restaurant operated by mama, poppa, son one, and son two. They glare at me as if I glow in the dark. Soon, they'll wish I glowed in the dark.
我离开教堂去吃午饭。我是那家由妈妈、爸爸、大儿子和小儿子经营的小型家庭餐厅里唯一的顾客。他们瞪着我，仿佛我会在黑暗中发光。很快，他们就会希望我真的会在黑暗中发光了。
The power keeps going on and off because of a thunderstorm. And the sky outside is nearly black. The muzak version of "A Whiter Shade of Pale" is playing. And it flickers too, so that every few seconds, it's dark and silent, which is a relief considering that the rest of the time, it's loud and the entire family have seated themselves across from me and gape without smiling. The eggplant on my plate is wonderful, but such is my desire for escape that I've never chewed so fast in my life.
因为雷雨，电力断断续续。外面的天空几乎是黑色的。背景音乐播放着《苍白的浅影》的商场版。它也在闪烁，所以每隔几秒钟，周围就陷入黑暗和寂静，考虑到其他时候声音震天响，而全家人坐在我对面不苟言笑地盯着我看，这反而是一种解脱。盘子里的茄子很美味，但我逃离的愿望如此强烈，以至于我这辈子从没嚼得这么快过。
How had it never hit me before? The whole point of The Godfather film is not to trust anyone outside the family. And whatever I may have thought while sitting in front of my VCR, I am not actually Sicilian. You may be surprised to learn, I bear no resemblance to Clemenza, Tessio, or any of the heads of the five families.
为什么我以前没意识到？《教父》电影的全部意义在于不要相信家族以外的任何人。无论我坐在录像机前时怎么想，我其实并不是西西里人。你可能会惊讶地发现，我和克莱门扎、泰西奥，或者五大家族的任何头目都没有半点相似之处。
If I were a character in the film at all, I'd be one of those pain-in-the-ass, innocent bystanders in the restaurant where Michael murders Solazzo. I'm the tuba player in Moe Greene's casino. I'm that kid who rides his bike past Michael and Kay on Kay's street in New Hampshire who yells, "Hello," and neither Michael nor Kay says hello back.
如果我真是电影里的一个角色，我也只会是迈克尔杀索拉索的餐厅里那些烦人的无辜旁观者之一。我是莫·格林赌场里的号手。我是那个在新罕布什尔州迈克尔和凯的街上骑车经过并大喊“你好”的男孩，而迈克尔和凯谁都没有回应。
I got sucked in by The Godfather movies' moral certainty, never quite recognizing that the other side of moral certainty is close-mindedness. Given the choice, I prefer chaos and confusion. Why live by those old world rules? Why not tell people outside the family what you're thinking? Trust me on this. It's a living. And if you see Michael, tell him it's nothing personal. It's only business.
我被《教父》电影的道德确定性所吸引，却从未意识到道德确定性的另一面是思想狭隘。如果有的选，我更喜欢混乱和困惑。为什么要靠那些老旧世界的规则生活？为什么不能告诉家族以外的人你在想什么？相信我，这就是生活。如果你见到迈克尔，告诉他这不是针对个人，这只是生意。
Sarah Vowell. Her story appears in her book Take the Cannoli. Her latest book is Assassination Vacation.
莎拉·沃威尔。她的故事出现在她的书《带上甜点》中。她最新的书是《刺杀假期》。
[MUSIC - "WHITER SHADE OF PALE" BY PROCOL HARUM]
[音乐 - 普洛柯哈伦乐队的《苍白的浅影》]
Act Two, Gangster's Daughter.
第二幕：黑帮女儿。
It was 1957, and I was 12. They said it was the largest funeral Las Vegas had ever seen. There were thousands of mourners. The pall bearers were men I had known, Gus Greenbaum, whose throat would later be slashed in Phoenix, Willie "Ice Pick" Alderman, who would die on Terminal Island, while serving time on a mob extortion rap, Joe Rosenberg, one of my father's partners, who was known as his mouthpiece, Nick the Greek, the famed odds maker. Squat Jewish men surrounded Uncle Chickie and me at the funeral, saying, "We don't expect trouble."
那是1957年，我12岁。他们说这是拉斯维加斯见过的规模最大的葬礼。有成千上万的哀悼者。护柩者都是我认识的人，格斯·格林鲍姆（后来在凤凰城被割喉），威利“冰锥”奥尔德曼（在终点岛服刑期间死于黑帮勒索指控），乔·罗森伯格（我父亲的合伙人之一，被称为他的传声筒），尼克（著名的赔率制定者）。矮小的犹太人在葬礼上围着奇奇叔叔和我，说：“我们没料到会有麻烦。”
Susan Berman's father was Davie Berman, a Jewish gangster who was one of the founders of modern Las Vegas, trusted confidant of Meyer Lansky, Frank Constello, and Bugsy Siegel.
苏珊·伯曼的父亲是戴维·伯曼，一位犹太黑帮成员，是现代拉斯维加斯的奠基人之一，也是迈耶·兰斯基、弗兰克·科斯特洛和巴格西·西格尔的亲信。
The son of a Russian-immigrant rabbinical student, he built his own gambling empire when he was just 16 and went on to become a bootlegger and bank robber, whose face appeared on dozens of "Wanted" posters. He was the brazen kid who engineered one of the first kidnaps for ransom, escaped death in a Central Park shoot-out, and was described by a detective on the front page of The New York Times as "the toughest Jew I ever met."
作为一名俄罗斯移民拉比学生的儿子，他在16岁时就建立了属于自己的赌博帝国，随后成为了私酒贩和银行劫匪，那张脸出现在几十张“通缉”海报上。他是个胆大妄为的孩子，策划了最早的绑架勒索案之一，在中央公园的枪战中逃过一死，被一位侦探在《纽约时报》头版形容为“我见过最硬核的犹太人”。
One of the most romantic and appealing notions about gangsters is the idea that they're cold-blooded tough guys while they're out in the world, but loving family men when they're at home. And while that's obviously not true for lots of real-life mobsters, it does actually seem to be true for Davie Berman. When his wife was ill and away from home for months, he was almost a new-age dad, 1990s-style dad, taking care of his daughter himself, spending time with her every day, helping her with her math homework in the casino's money counting room. Davie Berman was an owner of the Flamingo and Riviera hotels. And in those same rooms, they would skim the profits off for his mob bosses back east.
关于黑帮最浪漫、最吸引人的概念之一是，他们在外面是冷酷无情的硬汉，但在家里却是慈爱的顾家好男人。虽然这对许多现实生活中的暴徒来说显然不是真的，但对戴维·伯曼来说，这似乎确实是事实。当他的妻子生病离家数月时，他几乎成了新时代的爸爸，那种1990年代风格的爸爸，亲自照顾女儿，每天花时间陪她，在赌场数钱室帮她辅导数学作业。戴维·伯曼是火烈鸟酒店和里维埃拉酒店的老板。而在这些相同的房间里，他们会将利润捞走，上交给东部的黑帮头目。
This is an excerpt from Susan Berman's memoir Easy Street. The book is filled with scenes of this odd collision of worlds. Her father's world, she writes, was dangerous and violent and severe. But he crafted a childhood that seemed to her at the time to be completely normal. She had no idea about his criminal ties.
这是苏珊·伯曼回忆录《容易的街道》的节选。书中充满了这种奇怪世界碰撞的场景。她写道，她父亲的世界是危险、暴力和严苛的。但他为她营造了一个在当时看来完全正常的童年。她根本不知道他的犯罪背景。
I thought we had no house key because, as he said, "Somebody is always home." Mob members never carry keys, because if they're kidnapped, a rival could get to their families. My father was austere. He didn't gamble, drink, or smoke.
我以为我们没钥匙，是因为正如他所说，“总有人在家里。”黑帮成员从不携带钥匙，因为如果被绑架，竞争对手可能会找上他们的家人。我父亲很朴素。他不赌博、不喝酒、也不抽烟。
He told me he didn't like to stay in small rooms for a long time because he felt confined. I later learned that he had served seven years in Sing Sing, four in solitary confinement on a 12-year sentence. I thought we had no checking account because, as he said, "Everybody knows us here. We just use cash." Mob members prefer to keep cash boxes and few visible assets.
他告诉我他不习惯长时间待在狭小的房间里，因为他感到压抑。后来我才知道，他在新新监狱服刑了七年，其中四年被单独监禁，刑期总共12年。我以为我们没有支票账户，是因为正如他所说，“这儿的人都认识我们。我们只用现金。”黑帮成员更喜欢存放现金盒，几乎没有可见资产。
He told me our late night jaunts to Los Angeles were a vacation. He'd wake me and tell me to get dressed. We'd drive to McCarran Field and fly to LA. I'd be kept at the Beverly Wilshire Hotel for a few days with a couple of his men friends.
他告诉我我们深夜去洛杉矶是去度假。他会叫醒我，让我穿好衣服。我们会开车去麦卡伦机场，然后飞往洛杉矶。我会和他的几个朋友住在比佛利威尔希尔酒店几天。
They took me to Uncle Bernie's toy store in Beverly Hills to drink lemonade from the lemonade tree. And we ordered coffee ice cream in our room from MFK's drug store in the hotel. Then my father would reappear magically after two days and take me to the Brown Derby for dinner. We'd sit under Ingrid Bergman's picture. And he'd order "lamb chops with pink skirts for Susie" and put me on a red, leather child seat, so I could join in the conversation. In fact, these "vacations" were flights to freedom when there was mob unrest, and I was in danger.
他们带我去了比佛利山庄伯尼叔叔的玩具店，喝柠檬树的柠檬水。我们在房间里订了咖啡冰淇淋，来自酒店里MFK的药店。然后我父亲会在两天后神奇地出现，带我去棕德比餐厅吃饭。我们坐在英格丽·褒曼的照片下。他会点“苏茜的带粉色裙边的羊排”，并把我放在红色皮革的儿童座上，这样我就可以加入谈话了。事实上，这些“假期”是黑帮动乱时的逃生飞行，当时我正处于危险之中。
I knew my father's partners only from a child's perspective, the same way I knew my father. There was Willie Alderman, called "Ice Pick" Willie in his youth because he allegedly killed people with an ice pick. Willie was my favorite, a big, lumpy, silent man who greeted me every day with, "How you doing, Susie?" He was always at my father's side.
我从孩子的视角认识我父亲的伙伴们，就像我认识我父亲一样。有威利·奥尔德曼，年轻时被称为“冰锥”威利，因为据称他用冰锥杀人。威利是我最喜欢的，一个大块头、沉默寡言的男人，每天见面都会问我：“苏茜，你好吗？”他总是跟在我父亲身边。
There was Gus Greenbaum, a junkie and alleged killer. Gus was an older, dark-skinned man who smoked cigars and growled. He never paid any attention to me and never smiled. Once I kicked him as hard as I could in the ankle just to prove I existed. He said, "Davie, the kid takes after you." I asked my father if he had kicked big, mean men too. But my father said, no, and not to kick Gus again.
还有格斯·格林鲍姆，一个瘾君子和涉嫌杀人者。格斯是一个年纪较大、深色皮肤、抽雪茄并咆哮的男人。他从不注意我，也从不微笑。有一次我用力踢他的脚踝，只是为了证明我的存在。他说：“戴维，这孩子随你。”我问我父亲他是否也踢过高大、刻薄的男人，但我父亲说没有，也不要再踢格斯了。
My father's mother, Clara, or Bubby to me, would show up unannounced at our home in Las Vegas once a month for her "pay-as-you-eat Shabbes dinner." Around 2:00 PM on a Friday, Bubby would pound on the front door, yelling, "Davie, Lou, Susie, let me in. Hurry up." Of course, my father was never home from the hotel in the afternoon, but she'd act as if he should have been. She'd run all over the house looking for him, then go right into the kitchen and sneer, "So where's Davie? Working again?"
我父亲的母亲，克拉拉，我叫她奶奶，每月会不请自来地出现在我们拉斯维加斯的家中，做她的“吃多少给多少安息日晚餐”。周五下午两点左右，奶奶会敲前门，大喊：“戴维，卢，苏茜，让我进去。快点。”当然，我父亲下午从不出酒店回家，但她表现得好像他应该在那儿。她会在房子里跑来跑去到处找他，然后直接走进厨房冷笑道：“那么戴维在哪？又在工作吗？”
Without waiting for an answer, she'd throw down her shawl and start unpacking two huge needlepoint bags full of groceries. She was in a frenzy, her white hair standing up in wisps as it came out of her bun. She was short, and stout, and smelled like old rouge. As soon as she washed the carrots for the matzo-ball soup, she yelled at our bodyguard, Lou, to "Come and chop these carrots into little pieces." Lou dutifully went into the kitchen. She took an egg beater from her purse and started making matzo balls and washing the chicken.
不等回答，她就会扔掉披肩，开始从两个巨大的针织袋里卸下杂货。她陷入了疯狂，白发随着从发髻里脱落而变得蓬松。她个子不高，胖乎乎的，闻起来像旧胭脂。她一洗完做丸子汤的胡萝卜，就冲我们的保镖卢大喊：“过来把这些胡萝卜切成小块。”卢顺从地走进厨房。她从钱包里拿出打蛋器，开始做汤圆并洗鸡肉。
After about an hour of intense preparation, during which she yelled at me to, "Stay out of my goddamn way," and said, "ach" several times, and "oy vay" if Lou wasn't fast enough on the chopping. Bubby hit the telephone and had all my father's friends paged in the casino. "Hello, Gus? Clara Berman. I'm making a Shabbes meal at Davie's tonight. Be here at sundown. You eat good," she'd say, as she rang up Willy, Joe, Mickey Cohen, and others, usually about eight men.
经过大约一个小时的紧张准备，期间她对我大喊“别挡道”，说了好几次“唉”，如果卢切得不够快，还会说“我的天啊”。奶奶开始打电话，让赌场里所有的朋友都传唤。“喂，格斯吗？我是克拉拉·伯曼。今晚我在戴维家做安息日晚餐。日落之前赶到。你们会吃好的。”她说，接着打电话给威利、乔、米基·科恩等人，通常大约有八个男人。
Around 6:00 PM, the sleek, dark Cadillacs would roll up. Gus, Joe, Mickey, Willie, and others arrived, and the hungry Jewish men took their places around our table. My father entered with an expression that said, "Oh, no, not again." But he kissed Bubby hello and sat down too. They ate with the gusto of men starved for a matzo ball. It was always a silent dinner except for slurping noises from the soup bowls.
大约下午6点，锃亮的黑色凯迪拉克会开过来。格斯、乔、米基、威利等人到达，饥肠辘辘的犹太男人们坐在我们的餐桌周围。我父亲进门时表情写着：“哦，不，又来了。”但他还是亲吻了奶奶，也坐了下来。他们吃得像饿死鬼一样，对丸子狼吞虎咽。这总是一场沉默的晚餐，除了汤碗里发出的呼噜声。
Bubby lit the menorah on the mantle. She kept shoving food onto my father's plate, saying, "Davie, you're too thin." And Gus came in for chiding if he didn't finish every drop. "Whatsa matter? You got an ulcer from the hotel business? You can't finish the tsimmes?"
奶奶点燃了壁炉上的烛台。她不停地往我父亲盘子里堆食物，说：“戴维，你太瘦了。”如果格斯没吃完每一滴，也会遭到训斥。“怎么回事？酒店生意让你得胃溃疡了？这炖菜你都吃不完吗？”
When the strudel was gone, Bubby would remove her apron and announce, "Fine, first you eat, then you pay. I need gelt for my City of Hope project." And she'd go to each man and hold out her fat hand.
当馅饼吃光后，奶奶会脱下围裙宣布：“好了，先吃饭，后结账。我需要钱给我的希望之城项目。”然后她会走到每个男人面前，伸出胖乎乎的手。
My father looked embarrassed to death and said, "Momma, I'll give you the money. You promised you'd never do this again. Please?" But she knew her victims. $100 bills flowed out of their pockets while I watched in fascination. She put a rubber band around the take and threw it into her needlepoint bag.
我父亲看起来尴尬透顶，说：“妈妈，我会给你钱。你答应过再也不这么做了。求你了？”但她了解她的受害者。100美元的钞票从他们口袋里流出来，我看得津津有味。她给这些钱套上橡皮筋，扔进她的针织袋里。
Susan Berman's memories of Jewish gangsters and their gangster-style Jewish mothers will continue in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
苏珊·伯曼关于犹太黑帮和他们黑帮风格犹太母亲的回忆将在芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台的节目继续中播出。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, invite a variety of writers, reporters, and performers to tackle that theme. Today's program, The Mob. What we think we know about the mob, and what's actually true. We're in the middle of Act Two of our program, Mobster's Daughter.
这里是《此美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们会选择一个主题，邀请各种作家、记者和表演者来探讨这个主题。今天的节目主题是：黑帮。我们认为我们了解关于黑帮的事情，以及什么是真实的。我们正处于节目第二幕的中间，黑帮的女儿。
So let's say that your father is a big-time gangster and, like the men in The Godfather movies, actually does try to protect you from ever knowing what exactly he does for a living. What happens when you find out? Well, Susan Berman's father died of natural causes when she was 12. Her mother died a year later. And the first time anyone directly told her about her father's underworld ties was when she was in college. Another student told her about this new book that talked about what her father really did in Las Vegas.
假设你父亲是一个大牌黑帮分子，而且像《教父》电影里的男人们一样，确实试图保护你，让你永远不知道他到底以什么为生。当你发现时会发生什么？嗯，苏珊·伯曼的父亲在她12岁时因自然原因去世。她母亲一年后去世。第一次有人直接告诉她关于她父亲地下关系的事是在她上大学的时候。另一名学生告诉她一本新书，书里谈到了她父亲在拉斯维加斯到底做了什么。
I rushed to Martindale's Book Store, which was in Beverly Hills, no longer existent, and quickly found this book The Green Felt Jungle. There was a huge display of them. And I quickly looked at the index, "Davie Berman." And it did. It had a whole chapter on the Flamingo Hotel and Ben Siegel's death.
我冲进马丁代尔书店，它在比佛利山庄，现在不存在了，很快找到了这本书《绿毡丛林》。那里陈列着很多这本书。我快速看了索引，“戴维·伯曼”。确实有。里面有一整个章节讲述火烈鸟酒店和本·西格尔之死。
And it said that after Ben Siegel was dead, that Davie Berman-- and then in parentheses, "Who could kill a man with one hand behind his back." And a little later in the chapter, it said that he had been "wounded in a shoot-out with an FBI man in Central Park and done 11 years in Sing Sing." And then it went on to talk about his other partners. Well, I started to throw up in the book store. I was so shocked.
书中说在本·西格尔死后，戴维·伯曼——然后在括号里写着“一个能单手反背杀人的人”。在章节后面，它说他“曾与中央公园的一名FBI人员进行枪战并受过伤，在新新监狱服刑11年”。接着它继续谈论他的其他合伙人。嗯，我在书店里开始呕吐。我太震惊了。
You literally threw up in the bookstore?
你真的在书店里吐了？
Literally. How gross, right? It was just a visceral reaction. I couldn't believe it. And of course, I didn't think it was true.
真的。多恶心，对吧？那只是本能反应。我不敢相信。当然，我不认为那是真的。
As Susan Berman describes in her memoir Easy Street, she worked so hard at believing this wasn't true that eventually, she forgot the incident ever happened. Years later, she was a reporter for the San Francisco Examiner and interviewed Jimmy Hoffa just a month before he vanished. He and his men all knew her dad. One of them said he was, quote, "much smarter than the guys running the outfit now," end quote. And still, she did not want to believe that her dad was with the mob. Finally, when somebody showed her her father's FBI files, finally then, reluctantly, she believed.
正如苏珊·伯曼在她的回忆录《容易的街道》中所描述的那样，她非常努力地相信这不是真的，以至于最终，她忘记了这件事曾发生过。多年后，她是《旧金山观察家报》的记者，在吉米·霍法失踪前一个月采访了他。他和他的手下都知道她父亲。其中一个人说他，引用的话，“比现在运作这个机构的人聪明得多”。即便如此，她还是不想相信她父亲与黑帮有关系。最后，当有人把她父亲的FBI档案给她看时，她才勉强相信。
Terri Dalessio had a similar rude awakening. Her uncles and father were gangsters on Staten Island from before World War II. They ran numbers, bootlegging, the longshoremen's union, the works. She has pictures of herself with Robert De Niro. Some of The Godfather locations, she says, were filmed at her real-life godfather's house on Staten Island.
特里·达莱西奥也有过类似的粗鲁觉醒。她的叔叔和父亲是二战前史坦顿岛的黑帮分子。他们经营数字博彩、走私酒、码头工人工会，无所不包。她有自己和罗伯特·德尼罗的合影。她说，一些《教父》的拍摄地点就在她现实生活中的教父史坦顿岛的家里拍的。
She found out about her own family's business when she was 14, by accident. She was passing a candy store, and she saw photos of her family on the front page of a newspaper called The Mirror. She couldn't believe it.
她在14岁时偶然发现了自己家庭的生意。她路过一家糖果店，在报纸《镜报》的头版看到了家人的照片。她不敢相信。
And I said, no. My father? My uncles? My names? So I asked my mother. She said, "That's your father's business."
我说，不。我父亲？我的叔叔们？我的名字？所以我问我母亲。她说：“那是你父亲的事。”
So I'm a Mafia daughter. Well, here I go. And I went. I started to rebel. I ran away. I went to Pocono Mountains to find my grandmother, and hitchhiked all the way with two friends of mine.
所以我是一个黑帮女儿。好吧，我也要走了。我开始反抗。我离家出走。我去了波科诺山找我奶奶，和我的两个朋友一路搭便车。
And I never made it to the house. I got tired, and the two fellows that were with me tired. And we broke into a farmhouse to get something to eat and rest. And I found a shotgun, and I found bullets, shells for the shotgun, and I just proceeded to shoot the house up.
但我没到那房子。我累了，跟我一起的那两个伙计也累了。我们闯进了一处农舍找吃的休息。我发现了一把猎枪，还发现了子弹，也就是猎枪的弹壳，我就直接把那房子打烂了。
So where it came from, I don't know, this fury. It was festing in me. We got away with it because my father paid $1,500 for repairs. In those days, that was a lot of money. And I didn't get spanked or anything. I just got, "You know, you shouldn't do things like that." But I did.
所以我不知道这股怒气从哪里来的。它在我心里溃烂。我们逃脱了制裁，因为我父亲赔了1500美元作为维修费。在那个年代，那是一笔巨款。我没被打屁股之类的。我只是被告知：“你知道，你不应该做那种事。”但我做了。
All this festered inside me. And I decided that I wasn't going to be called Johnny Dee's daughter anymore. I was gonna make my own reputation and be Terri Dee. I looked older than what I was. And I would be drinking in any bar I could get into with my friends.
这一切在我心里溃烂。我决定我再也不要被称为强尼·迪的女儿了。我要建立自己的声誉，成为特里·迪。我看起来比实际年龄大。我会和朋友们去任何我能进的酒吧喝酒。
My dad had every cop in that area on the payroll. They would get a $50 reward if they found me. So if I saw anything walk in the door with a suit on, I knew it was a detective, and I'd hide under the table or run out of the bar.
我父亲在那一带有所有的警察领工资。如果他们找到我，能得到50美元奖金。所以如果我看到穿西装的人走进门口，我就知道是侦探，我会躲在桌子底下或者跑出酒吧。
You have to understand, Staten Island was a very small area in those days. And my family ran Staten Island. In my early days, I could pick up the phone and say, "Mary, connect me with my aunt." And the operator would just connect me.
你要明白，史坦顿岛在那个年代是一个很小的地方。我家族运营着史坦顿岛。在早期，我可以拿起电话说：“玛丽，帮我连我姑妈。”接线员就会直接帮我接通。
My father used to say to me, "Why don't you meet a nice man?" "Who am I gonna meet, dad? A lawyer? A judge? A cop? Who would you like me to go out with? I'm Johnny Dee's daughter. Who is gonna go out with me but somebody who wants to impress you?" Common sense.
我父亲常对我说：“你怎么不找个好男人？”“找谁？爸爸？律师？法官？警察？你希望我和谁出去？我是强尼·迪的女儿。除了那些想给你留下深刻印象的人，谁会跟我出去？”常识嘛。
My father-- I was the first born. I was a girl. He cried for two weeks because he wanted a boy. A year later came a boy. I have a brother one year younger than me. But he never let go of me as his son-daughter. So I went to all the fights in Greenwood Lake, Joe Lewis, all-- I was just a little bit of a thing. And everything he did, he dragged me with him. So I was like his son.
我父亲——我是长女。我是个女孩。他哭了两个星期，因为他想要个男孩。一年后，来了一个男孩。我有个比我小一岁的弟弟。但他从未放开我，把我当成他的“儿子-女儿”。所以我去了格林伍德湖所有的拳击比赛，乔·路易斯，等等——我当时只是个小不点。他做的一切，都会把我带上。所以我就像他的儿子。
I have been on sit-downs, one of the very few women I know that ever were. And here I am, sitting there like, I'd think, "Who the hell I am?" But mentally, I have the mind of a man.
我参加过秘密会议，是我认识的极少数女性之一。我就坐在那儿，我想：“我到底是谁？”但在精神上，我拥有男人的思维。
So my gambler husband owed a lot of money to two guys, who were like lower enchalant in the mob. And they came to my house, and they told my twins, 12 years old, "You tell your father--" and it wasn't their father-- "You tell your father that we're gonna burn the house down, burn his bar down, and burn his car down." Well, when I heard that, I went insane, because this man was on his way out anyway.
我的赌徒丈夫欠了两个人一大笔钱，他们就像黑帮里的底层喽啰。他们来到我家，告诉我的12岁双胞胎：“你们告诉你们父亲——并不是他们亲生父亲——你们告诉你们父亲，我们要烧掉房子，烧掉他的酒吧，烧掉他的车。”嗯，当我听到那个时，我疯了，因为这个男人无论如何都要走了。
So I just simply went to the bar where they hung out with a shotgun. I walked in the bar, big as day with a shotgun, in broad daylight. I said, "Are you so-and-so? And are you so-and-so? Well, let me tell you something. You better not touch my house, my car, or my business, because they're mine. I don't owe you any money. They don't belong to the gambler. They're mine. So if I see your car pull up in my driveway, I will shoot you."
所以我带着猎枪直接去了他们常待的酒吧。我大白天带着猎枪走进酒吧，气势汹汹。我说：“你是某某吗？你是某某吗？好吧，让我告诉你一件事。你最好别动我的房子、车或生意，因为它们是我的。我不欠你们钱。它们不属于那个赌徒。它们是我的。所以如果我看到你们的车开进我的车道，我就开枪。”
And one day, they pulled up to tell me everything was OK. And I did fire at the car. They just took off. [LAUGHING] I slept with a shotgun under my bed.
有一天，他们开车过来告诉我也没事了。我确实朝车开了枪。他们直接逃了。[笑] 我睡觉时床下都放着把猎枪。
I loved the violence at the time. I caused my own violence. Anyone who wanted to kill my husband knew they should not do it with me around. So that's why wherever we went, we went together. I'd walk in front of him. They had no right to hurt me because of my family. That's one thing that was honored.
我当时热爱暴力。我引发了我自己的暴力。任何想杀我丈夫的人都知道不应该在我身边动手。所以这就是为什么无论我们去哪，我们都在一起。我走在他前面。他们没权利因为我的家族伤害我。那是被尊重的一件事。
I'm going to find this picture sooner or later. I have an album here, "This is Your life." Here it is. This is the house my family has in the Pocono Mountains. It's a mansion.
早晚有一天我会找到这张照片。我这里有个相册，“这就是你的一生”。找到了。这是我家族在波科诺山拥有的房子。那是一座豪宅。
Three-mile lake with an island in the middle. Marble imported from Italy. Bathtubs enough to fit three people, four people. Everything was imported marble from Italy. Had a five-car garage. Upstairs was a bathroom and four bedrooms for the servants. And this is what I was raised in.
三英里长的湖，中间有个岛。大理石是从意大利进口的。浴缸大到能容下三四个人。一切都是进口的意大利大理石。有五车位的车库。楼上是一个浴室和四个仆人卧室。这就是我长大的地方。
I now live in one room. I have a table. I have an air filter, an air conditioner. I have a TV, telephone. I live in a room. And I am perfectly happy in this room.
我现在住在一个房间里。我有一张桌子。我有空气过滤器，有空调。我有电视，电话。我住在一个房间里。而且我在这个房间里非常开心。
Theresa lost all her money. Married four times. One of her husbands and one of her fiances were shot to death in front of her. Her life today barely resembles the life that she had as a girl. But even today, in her 60s, living in a hospice, Theresa still reverts to her gangster daughter ways sometimes.
特蕾莎花光了她所有的钱。结过四次婚。她的一个丈夫和一个未婚夫在她面前被枪杀。她今天的生活几乎不像她小时候的样子。但即使在今天，60多岁住在临终关怀中心，特蕾莎有时还是会回归到她黑帮女儿的习性。
Once in a while, if a situation pops up like it did one time when I lived in Greenwich Halfway House-- I was kitchen manager. This waiter who was one of the residents-- all the residents worked there-- served a dish to a woman. And this man sat in that seat and decided to pray. She started screaming, "Why are you praying over my food?" So he jumped up. This became a big scream.
偶尔，如果情况突发，就像我住在格林威治中途之家的时候——我是厨房经理。这个服务员是住户之一——所有的住户都在那工作——给一个女人端上一道菜。这个男人坐在那个位子上决定祈祷。她开始尖叫，“你为什么要对着我的食物祈祷？”所以他跳了起来。这演变成了一场大吵。
I said, "You," I told him, "Go down to your room and stay there until I tell you you can eat. Don't you ever raise your hand to a woman again." And he did. So that control came out of me at that point. I try not to do it because I find it very easy to do that.
我说，“你，”我告诉他，“回你的房间去，直到我让你吃饭之前一直待在那。永远不要再对女人动手。”他照做了。所以那种控制欲在那一刻从我体内爆发。我尽量不那样做，因为我觉得那样做太容易了。
I have two windows. And in one window is a t-shirt that says, "Free Chin." I wrote it with laundry marker. And in very small square print, it says, "Mind your own [BLEEP] business." That's if anyone asks me, "Who's the Chin?" If they don't know, that's it. I'm finished.
我有两扇窗户。其中一扇上贴着一件写着“解放下巴”的T恤。我用洗衣标记笔写的。在很小的正方形打印字里，它写着“管好你自己的[哔]事”。如果有人问我，“下巴是谁？”如果不认识，那就这样吧。我不想再多说了。
Theresa [? Mirable ?] in New York. She spoke with Blue Chevigny and Joe Richman.
特蕾莎·[？米拉布尔？] 在纽约。她与布鲁·舍维尼和乔·里奇曼交谈。
I'm 60 years old now. I've seen it all. And I want to tell about it. I want my book. I want my HBO special.
我已经60岁了。我什么都见过。我想讲出来。我想要我的书。我想要我的HBO特别节目。
Before Theresa, we heard Susan Berman, author of the book Easy Street, who we taped years ago. Since then, Berman was found dead in her apartment on Christmas Eve in the year 2000, killed by a single gunshot to the back of the head. Police say the prime suspect in her murder is not affiliated with the mob. She was 55 years old at the time.
在特蕾莎之前，我们听到了苏珊·伯曼的声音，她是《容易的街道》一书的作者，我们几年前录制的。此后，伯曼在2000年平安夜被发现死在公寓里，后脑部中枪身亡。警方称，她谋杀案的主要嫌疑人与黑帮无关。她去世时55岁。
Act Three, Neighbors To The Mob. The mob, the traditional godfather, big city, Cosa Nostra, Robert De Niro-movie kind of mob has not been doing very well. Vincent "Chin" Gigante, for example, tried to evade prison by spending years dressing like somebody incompetent to dress himself, peeing in public in a bathrobe, seeking the insanity defense, and failing.
第三幕：黑帮邻居。黑帮，传统的教父、大城市、西西里黑手党、罗伯特·德尼罗电影那种黑帮一直混得不太好。例如，文森特·“下巴”·吉甘特，试图通过多年打扮得像个生活不能自理的人，在公共场合穿浴袍小便，寻求精神错乱辩护，结果失败了。
Mafia expert Jerry Capeci is a columnist for The New York Sun. He also writes for the authoritative ganglandnews.com website. He's the author of several books about the mob, most recently The Complete Idiot's Guide to the Mafia. He says there are still 550 to 600 mobsters in New York. But times are tough for them, mostly due to effective law enforcement.
黑手党专家杰瑞·卡佩奇是《纽约太阳报》的专栏作家。他还为权威的ganglandnews.com网站撰稿。他是几本关于黑帮的书的作者，最近的是《黑手党完全傻瓜指南》。他说纽约现在还有550到600名黑帮成员。但他们的日子很难过，主要是因为有效的执法。
Oh, there's no question about it. The law enforcement efforts have gone a long way to remove the gangsters from the labor unions, from many industries where they ruled supreme. Another problem that they're facing is these federal murder and racketeering indictments are putting more and more gangsters in prison for life. And so that the Commission, the ruling body of the mob, has decreed a ban on sanctioned murders in the New York metropolitan area.
噢，毫无疑问。执法工作在清除工会和许多由他们统治的行业中的黑帮分子方面走了很长一段路。他们面临的另一个问题是，这些联邦谋杀和敲诈勒索起诉书正将越来越多的黑帮分子送进监狱终身监禁。因此，委员会，黑帮的统治机构，已下令禁止在纽约大都会地区进行未经授权的谋杀。
No more sanctioned killings for years now. The big guys don't want to do time for the murders, which raises the question, without killings, how will the mob stay the mob? Capeci also says the mob faces an odd recruiting problem right now. They don't want to bring in guys who will turn state evidence some day, as so many guys have. But gotta bring in someone for the mob to survive.
多年来没有未经授权的杀戮了。大佬们不想为谋杀服刑，这就引出了一个问题：没有杀戮，黑帮如何保持黑帮的地位？卡佩奇还表示，黑帮目前面临一个奇怪的招募问题。他们不想引进那些迟早会转作污点证人的人，因为很多人都这样。但为了黑帮生存，必须引进新人。
It's not around anymore, but there used to be this magazine called Double Take. Anyway, in the fall 1997 issue, there's this great black-and-white photo. It is here. It is a bunch of middle-aged white guys on the sidewalk outside this nondescript brick building. The guys on the left side of the photo are just standing around laughing and smiling. And then there's this empty space, kind of a no man's land.
那本杂志不在了，但曾经有一本叫《双重镜头》的杂志。总之，在1997年秋季刊，有一张很棒的黑白照片。在这里。是在这个普通砖墙建筑外人行道上的一群中年白人。照片左侧的人只是站在那儿说笑。然后有一段空地，类似无人区。
And then right in the center of the photo, dressed in white pants, white shoes, white socks, and a striped, casual shirt, hair perfectly coiffed, looking smug, powerful, happy, is Mr. John Gotti, then head of the Gambino crime family. Then as we scan, continuing our scan from left to right across the picture, there's another empty space, another no man's land. And then nearly the entire right side of the photo, like 1/3 of this image, is this guy who is walking toward the camera in the most menacing possible way. He's so close that he's out of focus. He takes up like 1/3 of the page, looking pretty much exactly like an angry Joe Pesci. Reaching toward the camera, his finger is nearly on the lens of the camera.
然后在照片的正中央，穿着白裤子、白鞋、白袜子，条纹休闲衫，发型完美，看着自负、强大、快乐，是约翰·戈蒂先生，当时的甘比诺犯罪家族头目。接着当我们扫描，继续从左到右扫视照片，有另一个空地，另一个无人区。然后几乎照片的整个右侧，像图像的三分之一，是这个家伙，他正以最可怕的方式向镜头走来。他太近了，导致焦点模糊。他占据了书页大约三分之一，看起来完全像个愤怒的乔·佩西。他伸手向镜头，手指几乎在相机的镜头上。
The name of this tiny, unglamorous building in the photo?
照片中这个狭小、不起眼建筑的名字？
It's called the Ravenite Social Group.
它叫乌鸦社会团体。
And it was on Mulberry Street?
它在桑树街？
It is still is on Mulberry Street at the corner of Prince Street.
它现在仍然在桑树街和王子街的拐角处。
That is, in little Italy, in New York City. Forget the gorgeous, brown-roomed house in The Godfather movie. This was John Gotti's clubhouse. Alec Wilkinson is a staff writer for The New Yorker magazine. His wife took the picture. And he, himself, had a special connection to the club.
也就是在纽约市的小意大利。忘了《教父》电影里那栋华丽、棕色房间的房子吧。这就是约翰·戈蒂的会所。亚历克·威尔金森是《纽约客》杂志的专职作家。他妻子拍了那张照片。而他本人与这个俱乐部有特殊的联系。
For seven years, beginning in 1979, I lived across the street from the club on the fifth floor of 250 Mulberry Street, a tenement. I looked down on the club and on the broad, flat roof of a garage next door. In a corner of the garage was a live poultry market. The name of the market was written in Chinese characters. Chinese women shopped there and old Italian women in black, who communicated by means of gestures with the Chinese men in white aprons covered with feathers and blood.
七年里，从1979年开始，我住在桑树街250号的一栋公寓楼五楼，就在俱乐部对面。我俯视着俱乐部和隔壁车库的宽阔平屋顶。车库的一角是一个活禽市场。市场的名字是用中文写的。中国妇女在那里购物，穿着黑色衣服的老意大利妇女通过手势与穿着满是羽毛和鲜血白色围裙的中国男人交流。
I always said hello to any of the Ravenites I passed on the sidewalk or saw standing in the doorway. But none of them ever said anything to me or even acted as if he had heard me. I was never invited into the club either. But from the street, when the doors were open, I could see a bar and an espresso machine. Across from the bar were tables, and chairs, and, beyond them, a back room with a television on a shelf. I lived in the apartment for nearly a year before I learned that the sullen and irritable-looking men, who came and went from the club and sat at the tables, playing cards with smudges of ash on their foreheads on Ash Wednesday, were gangsters.
我总是向我路过或在门口看到的所有“乌鸦”成员问好。但他们从不跟我说什么，甚至连听到了都装作没听到。我也从未被邀请进入俱乐部。但从街上，当门开着时，我能看到吧台和浓缩咖啡机。吧台对面有桌子和椅子，再后面是一个房间，货架上放着电视。我住在那公寓快一年了才得知，那些从俱乐部进进出出、坐在桌边玩牌、圣灰星期三额头上还带着灰烬的人是黑帮分子。
My building belonged to a Buddhist monk in Hong Kong. A woman named Susan held the lease on my apartment. She was a performance artist. The apartment had become available as a result of the response to a piece she had recently given in the living room, called "Why Don't You Come Up And See Me Sometime?" She had advertised the piece on posters she'd taped to walls and light poles around the neighborhood.
我的大楼属于香港的一位佛教僧侣。一个叫苏珊的女人掌握着我公寓的租约。她是个行为艺术家。这套公寓之所以空出来，是因为她最近在客厅里做的一个表演的反馈，名字叫“为什么你从来不来看看我？”她在邻里周围的墙壁和灯柱上贴了海报宣传这个表演。
On the evening of the performance, the audience gathered on the sidewalk outside the building. A friend of Susan's brought them upstairs. When they walked in the apartment, they saw Susan, a pretty good-looking woman, lying on her side with her chin in one hand, buck naked on a slowly turning platform. She had dyed her brown hair jet black, and she had an absent look in her eyes. Several culture hounds from the social club attended.
表演那天晚上，观众聚集在楼外的人行道上。苏珊的朋友把他们带上楼。当他们走进公寓时，他们看到苏珊，一个挺漂亮的女人，侧躺着，一只手托着下巴，光着身子躺在一个缓慢旋转的平台上。她把棕色头发染成了漆黑，眼睛里透着一种空洞。几个来自社交俱乐部的文化迷参加了。
And a few days after, the club extended to Susan an invitation to leave the neighborhood. The invitation was delivered by a functionary who crowbarred the door of her apartment off its hinges one afternoon while Susan was out and left the rest of the apartment undisturbed. It was not her first mistake. She lived alone and had friends come and go at all hours, some of them men, which had led members of the club to conclude that she was a prostitute.
几天后，俱乐部向苏珊发出了离开社区的邀请。这邀请由一个功能性人员传达，他一天下午在苏珊外出时用撬棍撬开了她公寓的门，让公寓其他地方保持原样。这不是她的第一次错误。她一个人住，朋友在任何时候来来去去，其中一些是男人，这导致俱乐部成员得出结论：她是妓女。
I had been living in Wellfleet, Massachusetts, on Cape Cod. Susan and I visited the Chinese agent who managed the building, and she told him that she was leaving the city and wanted to turn the apartment over to me, her cousin. I signed the lease and paid her $3,000, which was illegal. Then I went back to Cape Cod, and loaded my possessions into my car, and drove to New York, and parked in front of the social club.
我曾住在马萨诸塞州韦尔弗利特，在科德角。苏珊和我拜访了管理大楼的中国代理人，她告诉他她要离开这个城市，想把公寓转给我，她的表弟。我签了租约，付给她3000美元，这是非法的。然后我回到科德角，把我的财物装进车里，开车到纽约，停在社交俱乐部前。
A man came out as I was carrying a chair, and told me to move the car. I assumed I was parked illegally and that he was giving me some friendly, welcome-wagon-type advice. Then I read the parking sign on the light pole, and saw that I was legal, and said, "Thanks, it's OK." Another man came out of the club, and they started arguing. I heard the second man, say, "It's all right. It's all right. He's Susan's cousin." I don't know who he heard that from. The man who had told me to move said, "I don't give a damn who he is."
我搬椅子时，一个男人出来叫我把车挪走。我以为我违章停车，他在给我一些友好的、“欢迎来到社区”类的建议。然后我读了灯柱上的停车标志，看到我是合法的，说：“谢谢，没关系。”另一个人从俱乐部出来，他们开始争论。我听到第二个男人说：“没关系。没关系。他是苏珊的表弟。”我不知道他从哪听到的。那个叫我挪走的男人说：“我才不管他是谁。”
After I finished unloading my car, I drove over to the river, and drank some beers, and watched the sun go down over New Jersey. And when I came back, another car was parked in front of the club. The next morning, on my way to breakfast, I saw that the windshield, and windows, and headlights of the car had been shattered.
我卸完车后，开车去河边喝了几杯啤酒，看着太阳在新泽西落山。当我回来时，另一辆车停在俱乐部前。第二天早上，在去吃早餐的路上，我看到那辆车的挡风玻璃、窗户和车灯都被砸碎了。
The Ravenites kept a doberman named Duke. During the day, Duke paced in front of the club and the garage. And at night, he slept in the club. A short, fat guy named Mike looked after him. The garage belonged to a trucking company that hauled bananas and pineapples from the Brooklyn docks.
乌鸦帮养了一只叫杜克的多伯曼犬。白天，杜克在俱乐部和车库前踱步。晚上，它睡在俱乐部。一个叫麦克的矮胖家伙负责照顾它。车库属于一家从布鲁克林码头运送香蕉和菠萝的货运公司。
Mike's job was to watch the door. This was not a complicated job. Trucks came and went from the garage at the rate of about one every other day. Mike's position with the club was obscure. The lowest level of association seemed to be occupied by men in their 20s, mean-looking types with wiry bodies and spiteful, ratty faces. The more prestigious Ravenites arrived at the club in fancy, black cars. They left the cars on the sidewalk.
麦克的工作是看门。这工作不复杂。货车大约每两天左右进出车库一次。麦克在俱乐部的地位很模糊。最低级别的关联似乎是20多岁的年轻人，有着精瘦的身体和恶毒、像老鼠一样的脸。更有威望的“乌鸦”成员开着豪华的黑色汽车来到俱乐部。他们把车留在人行道上。
And the young men ran out of the garage with sponges and buckets of water and washed the cars while the gangsters were visiting the club. Mike never washed the cars. He was clearly above that. But he never spent much time inside the club either. Now and then, taking pains to emphasize his importance, he would say things, such as, "Kind of friends I have, you need a job done, they do it. Then they go to Italy for a while." One day, the doberman was gone. After that, when the club closed at night, an old man stood in the passageway, smoking cigarettes.
然后年轻人从车库跑出来，拿着海绵和水桶，在黑帮分子访问俱乐部时洗车。麦克从不洗车。他显然高于那个位置。但他也不常待在俱乐部里。偶尔，为了强调自己的重要性，他会说些话，比如：“我有这样的朋友，如果你有工作需要做，他们会搞定。然后他们去意大利待一会儿。”有一天，那只多伯曼不见了。之后，当俱乐部晚上关门时，一个老人站在过道里抽烟。
In addition to Mike, I was acquainted with a dark-haired, round-faced, slightly fleshy, and sinister-looking young man of about 30 named Norman. I often saw Norman behind the bar, and I assumed he was the Ravenite's bartender. Norman and Mike had an interest in a flock of pigeons that were kept in a coup on the roof above my apartment. For a while after I first moved in, I would hear a knock on the door. And I would open it to find Norman holding a plastic bucket. "He needed water for the birds," he said.
除了麦克，我认识一个黑头发、圆脸、稍微有点肉肉的、看起来阴险的30岁左右年轻人，叫诺曼。我经常看到诺曼在吧台后面，我以为他是俱乐部的调酒师。诺曼和麦克对屋顶鸽子笼里的一群鸽子感兴趣。我刚搬进来后的那段时间里，我会听到敲门声。我打开门发现诺曼拿着塑料桶。“他需要给鸟弄水，”他说。
While the bucket was filling in my bathtub, he would look around the apartment and ask what I did for a living. I had to have it explained to me by a neighbor, who lived down the hall, that Norman didn't need water. He was making sure on behalf of the Ravenites that I was not a cop.
当桶在浴缸里接水时，他会环顾公寓，问我是做什么工作的。楼下的邻居解释给我听，诺曼根本不需要水。他是在代表“乌鸦”确保我不是警察。
During the first year that I lived in the apartment, people would tell me that the Ravenites were the Mafia, and I didn't believe them. I thought they looked like people who wished they were in the Mafia, but didn't have the nerve or the intelligence or know the right people. For one thing, they seemed easily frightened. Whenever one of them had a dispute with a bicycle messenger or a delivery guy, he ran into the club or the garage for a wrench, or a tire iron, or a piece of lead pipe. Then he came back with three or four friends.
住在那公寓的第一年里，人们告诉我“乌鸦”是黑手党，我不相信。我认为他们看起来像那些希望成为黑手党，但没有胆量、智慧或不认识对的人的人。一方面，他们看起来很容易受惊。每当他们和送外卖或送快递的人发生争执，他就会跑进俱乐部或车库拿扳手、撬棍或一段铅管。然后带着三个或四个朋友回来。
The kids in the neighborhood had the same bullying streak. I often saw boys, wearing the blue sweaters and dark ties of the Catholic school around the corner, ambush drunks who wandered over from the Bowery. They set upon the frail, ragged figures like pack dogs. And when they had beaten the drunk to his knees, they ran away.
社区里的孩子也有同样的霸凌倾向。我经常看到穿着转角处天主教学校蓝色毛衣和深色领带的男孩伏击从包厘街流浪过来的醉汉。他们像一群狗一样扑向那些虚弱、衣衫褴褛的身影。当他们把醉汉打到跪地时，他们就跑了。
One morning after I had lived in the apartment for about a year, I learned what had happened to the doberman, and also why the windshield and the windows of the car had been shattered. A story on the front page of the New York Times said that the police had managed to hide microphones inside the club. The microphones had been in place only briefly before they were discovered and ripped out by the intended targets of the surveillance, the paper said. The conversations the police overheard had covered, quote, "numerous organized crime activities," unquote.
搬进公寓大约一年后的一个早上，我得知了多伯曼发生了什么事，以及为什么车的挡风玻璃和窗户会被砸碎。《纽约时报》头版的一篇报道称，警察成功地在俱乐部内安装了麦克风。报纸称，麦克风安装没多久就被调查目标发现了并被撕了下来。警方窃听的对话涵盖了，引用的话，“众多有组织犯罪活动”，未引用。
Among the Ravenites who were indicted as a result was Norman, who was identified as Norman Dupont of 32 Monroe Street. He and the others were offered immunity and then, of course, sent to jail for contempt since none of them would say anything. Norman was there for a year. He left the flock of pigeons in the care of some high school kids who showed up only occasionally, and most of the pigeons died.
结果被起诉的“乌鸦”成员中包括诺曼，他被确认为32号门罗街的诺曼·杜邦。他和另外一些人被给予豁免权，然后当然因为没人肯说任何话而被送进监狱藐视法庭。诺曼在那待了一年。他把鸽子托付给偶尔出现的高中生，结果大多数鸽子都死了。
The day the story was published, television reporters arrived to film dispatches in front of the club. A group of kids stood around them. Each time a reporter opened his mouth to speak into his microphone, the kids banged trash can lids together like cymbals. Eventually, the reporters got back into their cars and drove off except for one reporter who paid the kids to be quiet.
报道发表的那天，电视记者抵达现场在俱乐部前拍摄报道。一群孩子站在他们身边。每当记者张嘴想对着麦克风说话，孩子们就像敲镲一样撞击垃圾桶盖。最终，记者们回到了车里开车走了，除了一个付费让孩子保持安静的记者。
It turned out that I had parked in front of the social club on the day after the Ravenites had discovered that the police had been parking cars in the space where I had left mine. As a matter of routine, the Ravenites assumed that there were microphones in their clubhouse. So when they had something important to talk about, they went outside. Often, they leaned against the car, and, in the trunk of the car, was a cop who was listening to the gangsters' conversation. Sometimes, the gangsters leaned against the light pole which had a microphone in it. That the doberman never woke up from the tranquilizers the police have given him so that they could plant the microphones came out in the court records. The police misjudged the dose they gave the dog and said they felt bad about it.
事实证明，我把车停在俱乐部前的那天，是“乌鸦”成员发现警察一直把车停在我停车位的那天。作为一种常规操作，“乌鸦”假设他们的会所里有麦克风。所以当他们有重要的事情要谈时，他们就会去外面。通常，他们靠在车上，而车的后备箱里有一个正在听黑帮对话的警察。有时，黑帮分子靠在装有麦克风的灯柱上。法庭记录显示，多伯曼犬从没从警察给的镇静剂中醒过来，以便他们能植入麦克风。警方误判了剂量，并表示对此感到抱歉。
I often give a copy of the photograph of the Ravenites social club to friends as a present. My wife, a photographer, took it one afternoon in the spring just after John Gotti had been acquitted in the last trial that he would win. By then, I no longer lived on Mulberry Street. My wife had a studio on the Bowery, and she was walking to the subway when she saw Gotti. Gotti had become commander in chief of the Gambino family, whose headquarters the Ravenites club was, by having the former commander killed.
我经常送乌鸦社会俱乐部的照片给朋友作为礼物。我妻子，一位摄影师，在约翰·戈蒂赢得最后一场审判后的春天一个下午拍了这张照片。那时，我已不在桑树街住了。我妻子在包厘街有一个工作室，她正走向地铁时看到了戈蒂。戈蒂已成为甘比诺家族的总司令，而乌鸦俱乐部就是其总部，通过杀掉前任司令上任。
She pretended to be a tourist and asked if she could take his picture. She took three. And the guy on the right is saying, "Enough." Without looking at her, Gotti said, "Don't sell them," something that had not occurred to her.
她假装成游客，问是否可以拍他的照片。她拍了三张。右边的家伙说：“够了。”戈蒂看也没看她，说：“别卖它们”，这是她没想到的。
She went to a pay phone and called the New York Post and told them she had a picture of Gotti outside the Ravenite social club. The man who answered said, "You took it with a long lens, right?" She said, no, she had walked right up to him. There was a pause. The man told her to bring the picture right away. He said that the paper had a way of paying her so that no one would know her name. That was when she decided not to publish it.
她走到公用电话亭打了《纽约邮报》，告诉他们她有戈蒂在乌鸦社会俱乐部外的照片。接电话的男人说：“你是用长焦镜头拍的，对吧？”她说不，她是直接走上去的。有一阵沉默。那个人告诉她马上把照片带过来。他说报纸有支付报酬的方式，没人会知道她的名字。那就是她决定不发表这张照片的时候。
On the Fourth of July, Norman, and Mike, and some other Ravenites would fill wheelbarrows with fireworks, and dump them in the intersection of Mulberry and Prince, outside my building, and pour gasoline on the pile, and the flames would shoot up and blister the paint on the stoplight. Bottle rockets would rise to my window and throw off sparks. And the air would smell like gunpowder. Meanwhile, other Ravenites would light cherry bombs and M-80s, and toss them into garbage cans, and throw the lids on the cans. The fireworks would rip the seams on the cans and throw the lids into the air. And the explosion would rattle the frames of my windows and make my ears ring.
在独立日，诺曼、麦克和其他“乌鸦”成员会用独轮车装满烟花，把它们倒在我楼外的桑树街和王子街路口，并在堆叠上泼上汽油，火焰冲天，把红绿灯的油漆灼出泡泡。瓶装火箭升到我的窗前，迸出火花。空气中弥漫着火药味。同时，其他“乌鸦”成员会点燃樱桃炸弹和M-80，扔进垃圾桶，并把桶盖盖上。烟花会撕裂桶的接缝，把桶盖抛向空中。爆炸声震动了我窗户的框，让我的耳朵嗡嗡作响。
One year, some friends were having dinner with me, and their young son was with us. And the sparks from the bottle rockets coming in the windows and the flashes of light upset him. "The nerves in my skin are hurting," he said. I called the police. "The Mafia guys at the Ravenite social club are setting off fireworks," I said. And the cops said, "There's no such thing as the Mafia."
有一年，一些朋友和我一起吃晚饭，他们的儿子也在。瓶装火箭飞进窗户的火花和闪光让他很不舒服。“我皮肤里的神经在痛，”他说。我报了警。“乌鸦社会俱乐部的黑帮成员在放烟花，”我说。警察说，“这世上没有黑帮这回事。”
Alec Wilkinson. His latest book is Mr. Apology and Other Essays.
亚历克·威尔金森。他最新的书是《道歉先生及其他随笔》。
Well, our program was produced today by Julie Snyder and myself with Alix Spiegel and Nancy Updike. Our senior editor for this show was Paul Tough. Contributing editors Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, and Consigliere Sarah Vowell. Our staff includes Alex Blumberg, Diane Cook, Jane Feltes, Sarah Koenig, Amy O'Leary, and Lisa Pollak. Production help from Sam Hallgren and Chris Ladd.
好吧，我们的节目今天由朱莉·斯奈德和我自己制作，还有阿里克斯·斯皮格尔和南希·厄普代克。我们节目的高级编辑是保罗·塔夫。特约编辑杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克林和顾问莎拉·沃威尔。我们的工作人员包括亚历克斯·布隆伯格、黛安·库克、简·费尔特斯、莎拉·柯尼格、艾米·奥利里和丽莎·波拉克。萨姆·哈尔格伦和克里斯·拉德提供了制作帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Our website, www.thisamericanlife.org, where you still have a couple days left to do your Christmas shopping, and where you can also listen to our programs for absolutely free any day of the year. Or you know, can download today's program in our archives at audible.com/thisamericanlife. This American Life is brought to you by Public Radio International.
我们的网站，www.thisamericanlife.org，你还有几天时间去买圣诞礼物，你也可以一年中的每一天免费收听我们的节目。或者你知道，可以在audible.com/thisamericanlife从我们的档案中下载今天的节目。《此美国生活》由国际公共广播电台带给您。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight for our program by Mr. Torey Malatia, who describes the This American Life staff this way.
WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责，他这样形容《此美国生活》的工作人员。
Mean-looking types with wiry bodies and spiteful, ratty faces.
有着精瘦身体和恶毒、像老鼠一样脸的类型。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着《此美国生活》的更多故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。